your dream to be your favorite character
from TV this week a New York Times piece
detailed the rise in popularity of live
interactive experiences based on TV
shows so they're meant for super fans of
big budget shows like squid game
Bridgerton The Walking Dead and stranger
things which I believe is a show about
the vice
president basically they're a marketing
tool so the shows can retain fans
between Seasons where people post their
experiences on social media essentially
becoming part of the show's ad campaign
my favorite show is Road Rules which is
why my social media is going to be me
hanging out with Rachel and Shawn
Duffy
nice Mackie if you could live in a show
what show would you live in
Gutfeld um no I absolutely
right uh cat I actually came up with a a
quick list okay I'm ready uh uh it first
would be Smurfs cuz there's like 99 male
Smurfs and only one female Smurf so no
one would ask why someone doesn't have a
girlfriend Will and Grace same reason as
the
Smurfs Family Feud I get to make out
with the
guests Golden Girls cuz nowadays there
beov
scenes Sex in the City cuz maybe we we
could edit out the love
scenes Hogan's Heroes it would be
refreshing to see someone make fun of
Nazis on
television and my 600 lb life because I
could tell people I'm putting on 400 lb
for a
roll very very see I think for me I just
pick any cartoon so that you don't age
it's I it was okay you know how old the
bear is in barenstein Bears the mom is
27 years old and papa bear is
29 what what right right and then they
have a 10-year-old which means mama and
papa bear were teen parents oh which
makes me view the whole cartoon
differently than I did Scandal I know
bears get married younger
[Laughter]
though that is true Kennedy what about
you what show would you pick I would
pick the crown I love the crown so much
I love every season I love every episode
and I want to go and I want to sit and I
want to drink the Queen's cocktail which
is dubet and Jin shaken with ice and
then strained into a highball with ice
with a slice of orange and I just I I
want to drink with her sister Margaret
and the Queen Mother and be like he what
we going to do about Elizabeth she's
she's such a prig she's just gotten so
full of herself she's so dry pass the
Gin
granny um Charlie do you have a
TV well it's interesting because I'm
thinking that maybe I I uh did the wrong
lesson here um so do you are you do you
get to be a character in the in the in
the crown or just you're a lurker in the
crown I mean I would I would like to
think I'm a character but I'm probably
lurking trying to Bone a beef
eater I think that counts as a character
yeah I'm sure it does so do you not do
not a TV I'm trying to avoid the
question I actually I do we do have a
television um and you know what I'm
addicted to Modern Family that's good
great show but I wouldn't want to be in
that show um I would definitely want to
be in Duck Dynasty just because I would
be a lot more comfortable living in
Monroe Louisiana than I would wherever
modern if you want to be a part of Duck
Dynasty you just go to the Patriot
Awards or I could just go out my back
door actually right yeah that's
absolutely I'd feel right at home yeah I
I always wonder how you
live it's uh I think you you'd find it
very strange as soon as you walk out of
here I'm like where's he
going not to do the same thing I'm doing
that's for
sure what about you what show would you
pick uh well I used to like what I used
to watch that one show where they starve
these animals and make them fight each
other uh called America's Next Top Model
um
but yeah but I you know I'm a big fight
fan I love The Ultimate Fighter I love
to watch UFC uh the last event had 3.2
million people in Mexico watch it on one
TV um but no I I I love uh I love all
show Cobra Kai is my favorite show I
have to say out of all the shows Cobra
Kai I was a big Karate Kid fan and uh
you no one watches Cobra kai no no it's
a it's a I do know what karate is though
oh that's just that counts um but yeah
Cobra is my favorite yeah I just I I I
feel like it is a little weird because
it is just a marketing scheme like
they're not they're just saying do
advertising for free you don't actually
get to be in the show I mean but that's
what people think because they're
they're losing so much money and no one
advertises on anything anymore I mean
everything is all Netflix and Hulu like
no one watches commercials so I think
that's why the Dow does really well
because people only know Major Brands so
those are the stocks they buy um but but
no one watches anything so they have to
in order to make money they have to get
people to pay to do something and
they're just hoping that people are so
dumb that they'll be like oh this is
great I'm in Squid game am I dead yeah I
it could be a it could be a disaster too
cuz what if there's a Duck Dynasty show
and Dick Cheney signs
[Laughter]
up yeah I I don't know TV you're right
though it's like it's all streaming but
I used to I didn't grow up with cable
and I just would watch TV TV like when
people say it was better in the past I'm
not so sure that's true no they've never
watched love after walk up with you yeah
that's true seventh heaven you I used to
watch that it's like really bad it's
like a horrific show it's like some of
the lessons in that show I don't think
they're the right lessons to learn you
guys don't know what I'm talking about
oh you guys all had cable growing up did
you watch like Nickelodeon and stuff yes
yes did not have that oh we did not have
cable oh yeah oh no we didn't even have
Atari we got Atari after they stopped
making the the the the games I think my
parents got it like at a at a at at a
Goodwill somewhere ah you probably don't
even know what an Atari is I do it's
like a stick that plays video games
right it had a little red button yeah
it's true my friends had them yeah these
kids will never know like they have
World of Warcraft and like when I was a
frog had to cross a
pond that was that was the whole game
yeah you tried to to give away an Atari
to Goodwill they'll laugh right in your
face okay tell you where to stick that
joystick I'll tell you
what all right only a matter of time up
next experts acknowledge guys don't want
to go to
college hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else